um so like like let me get this straight
so you're you're gonna
um going to jail you turn yourself in
right sorry
um for you are you on probation are you
able to move around freely like what's
your status right now uh parole I had to
go up there to um I gotta go upstate and
catch a number of parole number so
so you had to go you had to go to
Delano's prison to reception I'm hungry
there like two three months yeah up
north is like like yeah man it was
Delano it was it was like three hours
away okay okay crazy [__] right
I put on everything I remember the day I
left uh to Delano in the in the in the
bus when we all got chained up caught
the chain it was March 29th you'll never
guess who was on that bus from who uh
Eric Holder [__] that kill nip I swear
to God oh everything I love he was he
was right there on the same bus and it's
crazy because I'm saying that I'm with a
few homies I'm with a homie from 60s too
yeah and then so I'm like um but he's in
a cage though he's like he was pc'd up
so he was in the cage but he was in the
in the last cage and I and I'm sitting
right here so like his cage is right
here and then I see him I see him just
look back on everything I love and I'm
like what the [__] I'm high too I'm
faded so
I'm like what the [__] and I tell the
homie I'm like hey I'm like bro I I
think that's old boy he's like and he
look at me like kind of disrespectful
like man you tripping you hot and you're
like you off drugs like you feel me and
then I was just like all right man bam I
go bang on his on his window boom boom
boom he looks back everybody on the bus
like
what the [__] I swear to God and then
he's like you Eric you Eric Holder he's
like yeah this [__] went crazy or
anything else he got pissed on and
Samosa it spit on they were pissing and
spitting on him in the bus man said hell
yeah squirting piss on his ass somebody
like him like can't beat like he has to
not be in general population because he
does as soon as we got to Delano
so look [__] bus was going crazy [__]
shaking everybody up boom boom as soon
as they found out it was him and then
um they stopped the bus over on the
freeway I mean y'all better chill out or
else we finna take ours back to the
county have to catch the whole chain
again so as soon as we got to Delano man
I'll tell you he covered in pissed I
don't know everything I left he covered
in pissed they take him out first they
take him out and um they put them away
like you know and then uh yeah he for
show PC left though yeah I feel like
there's just like certain people I feel
like you've been on a PC yard though
he's [__] you know like people love me
I'm saying like you don't even got to be
like Affiliated you just like yo you
[__] what you did was [__] bro yeah
even the homies Mexicans we tripping on
that [__] Mexicans love that bro family
100 did you ever did you have a
relationship with him no I didn't sadly
yeah I feel like I was I wasn't even
popping like that before you know that
happened yes that he's definitely like
my biggest inspiration I'll tell you
that is he like like in terms of like
his independency and uh because you're
independent for real for real a lot of
people fake independent you're
independent fake independent yes sir
I'll be doing it so it was really
through him like I swear I watched his
interviews you know like all that [__] A
lot of people say that they're like you
know like the music is one thing it was
incredible but like you also could just
like listen to him speak and get so much
gain so much information and like
career
yeah yeah and all that man what's your
favorite what's your favorite uh like
nip [__] like like a song or an album
obviously Victory lapse is only real
album you had a bunch of mixtapes yeah
right true story that's true story [__]
hard yeah
um the TMC the marathon all the original
[__] that's that's the you know how
should I be slapping
um yo so while you're in uh incarcerated
you obviously have money signed suede on
the project that just dropped rest in
peace to him man rest in peace man I'll
let my boy swag for real real sad
situation that happened to him um did
you guys see each other in in jail at
all uh we're in the same place with
different floors so but I heard he was
there I was trying to send a kite to him
and yeah you know but you know so you'll
be moving around and he had caught the
change before me he had one Upstate
before me so I was like [__] it I'm
[__] around see him in reception or
something but I haven't run into him but
uh yeah that's it that's it that [__]
crazy sad situation man like for you
like hearing about that in jail like I'm
sure it's it's it's got to be tough
right hell yeah that [__] was crazy I'm
like man I heard about that [__] right
I was on the toilet right somebody come
and tell me they're like oh you know I'm
like man that's some [__] yeah
that's some [__] you're like oh no
I'm like bro like I'm getting mad
because you know I hear rumors about
rappers
it's just a rumor yeah I get on the
phone I call I call my boy and he first
thing he says is like bro I was like I
just knew he said bro I was like damn
yeah she was [__] up I was like what
you mean like he alive though like no I
was like man that [__] that [__] it
didn't feel real to me because you feel
me was in the studio like a week before
we both turned ourselves in because he
turned himself in like a week or two
before me so we were in the studio
right there chilling chopping he was
just telling me he had a lot on his mind
too he was just like you know telling me
[__] who's making music
I'll probably see you in there you know
yeah bam that's what it was the last
time I seen him she was so sad man it's
crazy too because both you guys are like
leaders of like
a whole new generation I feel like of of
Mexican artists coming out of Cali that
um
to me like are making music everybody
can enjoy you know what I'm saying yeah
we're kind of talking earlier like you
know when I was growing up like there
was like Chicano rap which was cool like
shot a little Rob and like Mr Capone and
those guys like they were like extremely
like
right you really had to like
either be extremely [__] tapped in
with Mexican culture or be of like a
certain cloth to really appreciate it
because it was Chicano rap you know what
I'm saying so I feel like yourself money
sign suede peso peso free him like are
making records that like if you're just
like you guys are just making dope [__]
and kind of like the leaders of this new
[__] in La so it's dope to see like you
get out have your head on straight you
know what I'm saying like
sad man about suede though for sure
yeah that was another one like me and me
and you were talking like I mean dming
but him and I bro we were talking like
for like a year straight we just never
made the interview happen bro and I was
like damn bro and then he ended up
getting locked up and yeah it's a sad
situation man I'm sure he's got a lot of
uh I mean I hope he's got a lot of
unreal [__] that he does I know he does
hell yeah
that'll help you know
we got a gang [__] yeah yeah you guys
gotta get a bunch on really [__] yeah we
got some [__] yeah yeah classic [__] too
I just keep those right you know yeah
probably just keep them I mean or just
work it out with his family because why
not bro help help him you know he's got
he's got a
he's got one kid I think right I think I
seen
yeah I think he's got a baby yeah I've
seen that I don't know I mean you know
[__] that [__] goes towards his family
you know what I'm saying like I'm sure
he would want his family to eat off that
uh hell yeah for sure
um
for you man like how do you feel about
uh
where
because the perception of
being a Mexican in hip-hop I think is
starting to become more like you're an
artist I look at you like you're an
artist who just happens to be Mexican
you know what I'm saying yeah like
yeah you know what I'm saying but I'm
saying like for you do you feel that
that that like stigma going away where
it's like you know I feel like oh
Jeezy's help with that I feel like that
Mexican OT is helping with that you're
you're doing your thing with that but
like do you feel like you know now it's
like not as much of like
um an uphill battle to get people to
like respect you
hell no I feel like
look sometimes I feel like it's good but
then sometimes I feel like they do try
to boxes in but I mean I feel like we
just artists at the end of the day [__]
our skin color brown you know like we're
like an artist who just happens to be
like the music is dope yeah hell yeah
but I mean I feel like we're doing our
[__] I feel like they gonna they gotta
you know I mean we going crazy like
we're going down we're doing some like
bigger numbers than some artists who
it's just we just we rapping it's
hip-hop you know 100 I feel like it
shouldn't be uh we shouldn't be our own
category I agree I don't think we are
either I don't think we are either like
I don't think we are yeah no I think
that I don't think so but I think that
like there are still people who are like
oh yeah yeah like he's a dope Mexican
rapper and it's like well he's also just
a dope rapper
yeah he's just a rapper who's dope and
oh he's Mexican yeah yeah yeah like
Cypress Hill back that they were just
hard like you'd be like yo that's
Cypress Hill dog the [__] are
hard like yeah it's hard you understand
oh yeah